bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors je le disais
vous êtes médecin et directeur de
l'hôpital des soeurs du rosaire à
beyrouth la première question que j'ai
envie de vous poser dans quel état et
votre établissement est ce qu'il a été
épargné oui bonjour bonjour à tout
oui à l'hôpital et atteignent maintenant
il est presque totalement détruit on a
pu évacuer tous les passions à
l'extérieur de l'hôpital
on a pu les transférer dans les autres
hôpitaux jusqu'à maintenant on travaille
pas la sq l'hôpital
il est complètement détruit la structure
seulement des mets à face à une alliance
n'était pas d'électricité pas
d'équipement vient du tout on appelle du
plusieurs questionnaires à l'hôpital il
ya beaucoup de blessés et l'hôpital
actuellement il faut pas alors quatre
hôpitaux de la capitale ont été dévastés
comment s'organisent les hôpitaux deux
jours après la catastrophe est ce que
vous continuez à recevoir des victimes
actuellement en essai un peu de
l'établir l'infrastructure c'est à dire
de organisé un petit peu l' auld dans
l'hôpital de nettoyer tout ça mais n'ont
actuellement on peut pas le voir des
patients dans notre hôpital local
il était totalement détruit on n'a pas
d'instrument ans nadia et dans les
autres hôpitaux est ce que vous savez
s'il continue à recevoir des blessés
dans les hôpitaux ou au final on voit
semblablement ils peuvent encore
travailler
oui dans les hôpitaux à côté et reste
que quelques parties des bâtiments qui a
fonctionné oui oui dans les autres
hôpitaux il ya une partie qui n'a pas
fonctionné ce qui donne ensuite un nom
ds qui sont bondées où il ya encore des
capacités d'accueil pour l'instant
actuellement la capacité elle ne peut
être totalement saturé on essaye dont
don dans la partie où il ya beaucoup de
dégâts dont vous voyez les patients dans
les hôpitaux périphériques mais non dans
la partie centrale où il ya beaucoup de
de destruction les patients sont plutôt
en suède et dans les autres hôpitaux le
secteur hospitalier et est au bord de
l'effondrement raison de la crise
financière que subit libos et même bien
avant l aile international
elle arrive mais quels sont les besoins
prioritaires pour faire face à cet
événement tragique au liban pour dit la
vérité
comme vous avez dit c'est plutôt la
crise économique qui a quitté plus tôt à
à cette situation
donc il nous manque actuellement
beaucoup d'équipements de médicaments de
prothèses des prothèses surtout
chirurgicale peut être cardiaque on
décèle tout ça mais surtout les
matériaux et les équipements médicaux
qui nous manque beaucoup
où le personnel les médecins les
infirmières tout ça on arrive à gérer la
situation mais c'est surtout les
matériaux et les équipements médicaux et
les médicaments qu'ils nous montrent
justement concernant le corps
hospitalier comment s'organisent les
médecins les infirmiers on a vu beaucoup
de solidarité des noms de solidarité ces
derniers ces derniers jours oui je
remercie beaucoup
les pays qui nous soutiennent
actuellement qui on voyait aussi des
dettes pour nom surtout la flotte pour
le corps médical médecins et
d'infirmières on arrive à si vous voulez
à au mobile iad
où il ya un manque de personnel on
arrive à envoyer des médecins ou des
infirmières dans d'autres hôpitaux pour
la poudre pour soutenir les autres
institutions où il ya un manque mais on
a dit que j'allais pas et on n'avait pas
su comment est-ce que le pays va gérer
la crise du coronavirus et ses victimes
qui affluent de jour en jour
actuellement c'est très difficile mais
avant cette crise avant l'explosion on
faisait beaucoup d'attention en marché
selon les normes retours évitez la cité
cette crise virale cette épidémie mais
actuellement après l'explosion en arrive
toujours à gérer on met toujours des
marques qu'on en dise pension fille dit
tout
mais c'est très difficile du l'état
énorme des blessés vu la catastrophe
médical paramédical et aussi pour la
population vit actuellement se traiter
les difficiles surtout aussi avec le
monde de matthew et on arrive toujours à
gérer vous en tant que médecin pierre
maudet
qu'est ce que vous attendez du ministère
de la santé ce qu'il ya eu des annonces
qu'il ya eu une prise de parole du
ministre de la santé ahmad hassan
actuellement mois comme directeur
médical je vois le bernois des hôpitaux
surtout l'hôpital où je travaille c'est
surtout une aide pour rétablir
l'établissement de nouveaux c'est à dire
du moment beaucoup de matériaux
innovants beaucoup de d'équipement
médical toute façon ce taux si vous
roulez le problème financier total elle
s'étale le problème primordial c est le
problème financier
est ce qu'il ya une prise de parole du
ministre de la santé ce que le corps
médical s'est sentie rassurée ou écouter
pour vous dire la vérité jusqu'à
maintenant il ya toujours ce sentiment
si vous voulez entre deux ballons tête
de désespoir avec la situation sociale
et politique est actuellement économique
ça devient de plus en plus difficile et
jusqu'à maintenant non on n'a pas le
sentiment de gratitude qu'on va nous
aider
de quoi non prenez seule dent dans cette
bataille passé mon sentiment n'est sûr
merci beaucoup
pierre moure à boncourt a bel et bien en
tout cas je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin et directeur de l'hôpital et des
soeurs du rosaire à beyrouth merci